[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle édition du 78 lactu sur
TVfil 78 en direct si vous nous suivez à
18h voici les titres de ce 1ier octobre
le passage à 4 jours et demi pour
l'école loin de faire l'unanimité alors
que l'échéance de septembre 2014 pour sa
mise en place approche la comp station
anfle l'UMP vient notamment de lancer
une pétition pour demander un report et
un audit complet le théâtre de
Saint-Quentin à 20 ans seule scène
nationale des Yvelines à l'accueil 60000
spectateurs chaque saison le bilan le
projet nous en parlerons avec son
directeur Jacques Pornon qui sera en
plateau tout à
l'heure et puis vous rencontrerez aussi
ce soir thbao 5 ans il souffre
d'amiotrophie spinale une maladie rare
il est cette année l'un des ambassadeur
du Téléton qui se déroulera les 6 et 7
décembre on commence journal par l'image
de ce mardi l'improvisation qui s'invite
dans les transports en commun skibus
s'associe avec Déclic Théâtre la
compagnie de trappe pour sa campagne de
communication sur la validation des
titres de transport pour expliquer aux
clients l'importance de la validation
des interventions théâtrales sont
programmées jusqu'à la fin du mois de
novembre aujourd'hui ce sont les
passagers des lignes versaillaises qui
étaient concernés ils ont assisté au CET
d'un musicien et de deux comédiens
masqués pas d'inquiétude donc si vous
les rencontrez dans les prochains jours
sur le réseau de bus yvelinois c'est
drôle de personnage les bricoleurs du
dimanche qui restent mobilisés après la
décision de Matignon de commander un
nouveau rapport sur le travail le
weekend le collectif composé de salariés
dans l'une des représentantes était avec
nous hier soir annonce un rassemblement
mercredi demain donc rue de varen à
Paris dès 10h30 300 à 500 personnes sont
attendues le collectif soulligne que
l'emploi le dimanche en Île-de-France
dans les enseignes de bricolage
représente plus de 4500 salariés mais
aussi 20 % du chiffre d'affaires annuel
rappelons que le nouveau rapport
commandé par le gouvernement devrait
être remis d'ici la fin du mois de
novembre autre question qui divise
actuellement les nouveaux rythmes
scolaires pour ou contre la semaine de 4
jours et demi vous le savez peu de
communes ont décidé de franchir le cap
dès cette année 2013 dans les ivelines
on peut citer les cas de trappe ou
encore de poissie le maire d'élencour
l'UMP Jean-Michel fourgouss à lui décidé
de lancer une pétition pour le report de
cette mesure plus de 15000 signataires à
ce jour et la contestation qui enfle
avec une probable mobilisation nationale
le 13 novemb les précisions d'Olivier
Maniscalco les nouveaux rythmes
scolaires un sujet qui fait débat a en
cours le maire Jean-Michel Fourgous a
lancé une pétition nationale contre le
décret du ministre payon pour lui pas
question d'envisager la semaine de 4
jours et demi dans sa commune c'est une
mesure en plus vraiment profondément
injuste donc injuste inefficace sur les
résultats scolaires et surtout
infinançable le coût et est hors norme
et c'est pas sérieux on peut pas se
permettre aujourd'hui de de désorganiser
la vie des citoyens comme ça uniquement
parce que il y a quelques grands
penseurs qui ont sorti une idée mais
est-ce est-ce est-ce que cette idée a
été testée sur sur sur l'ensemble les
enfants c'est pas des jouets c'est pas
des c'est pas des souris de laboratoire
donc voilà sa pétition a déjà atteint
15000 signataires en quelques jours sur
le terrain les avis des parents lui
donnent raison il est 16h15 c'est la
sortie des classes à l'école jean-jores
de trappe depuis 6 semaines la réforme
des rythmes scolaires est appliqué dans
la commune c'est une journée de plus à
se réveiller à à 9h ou à enfin à 8h pour
aller le mercredi donc oui dans le
quotidien c'est plus de temps à l'école
moins d'activités extrascolaire en fait
parce que le mercredi les enfants ils
ont beaucoup d'activités et donc là on
était obligé de tout décaler quoi c'est
dur c'est dur les enfants sont beaucoup
plus fatigués
queauparavant fatigue des enfants
problèmes d'organisation pour les
parents les premiers retours sont donc
loin d'être encourageants du côté des
syndicats on pointe clairement du doigt
le manque de préparation de cette
réforme nous ce qu'on avait demandé
c'était déjà beaucoup plus de
concertation en amont le temps de
prendre de de discuter de façon à ce que
les choses puissent mieux s'organiser et
notre slogan c'était ni statuco ni
bricolage ce qu'on souhaitait c'était un
report à 2014 justement de façon à ce
que la concertation puisse s'organiser
de façon satisfaisante face à une telle
opposition la mairie de trappe préfère
pourtant rester optimiste on a toujours
donné la priorité aux enfants et à la
jeunesse à l'éducation et à la jeunesse
que rien ne soit par fait mais jamais
rien n'est parfait tout de suite du
premier coup jamais surtout quand il
s'agit de travailler sur de
l'humain et la réforme elle se calera au
bout du de 2 3 ans et même peut-être
avant je suis pas inquiette je ne suis
pas inquiète dans les ivelines communes
sur 262 ont fait le choix de changer
leur rythme scolaire dès cette rentrée
2013 lors du congrès des maires de
France le 18 novembre prochain le sujet
sera sûrement au cœur des débats dans
dans le département on compte neuf
délégués du Défenseur des droits leur
action aider les citoyens à régler leurs
conflits liés en grande partie à des
dysfonctionnements des services publics
au problèmes d'habitat de transport ou
encore de discrimination sociale ils ont
rendu leur rapport au président leur
rapport 2012 c'était au début du mois
l'occasion de faire le point avec Claire
Cambier ces personnes sont les neuf
délégués départementaux du Défenseur des
droits bénévolement ils aident à
protéger les droits et libertés de
chacun connu pour faciliter les
relations entre l'an
le rle va bien de la protection de
l'enfance à la lutte contre les
discrimination nous n'avons pas les
pouvoir d'un
juge mais nous pouvons aider à débloquer
des situations qui paraissent insolubles
simplement parce que nous avons le temps
d'étudier les problème et de les
présenter aux gens que ça concerne quoi
au m en cause et donc c'est un métier de
de facilitateur qui qui est important en
2012 174 ont été comptabilisé dans les
ivelines dans 86 % des cas pour des
problèmes avec les services publics en
île-de-fance la population étrangère
étant plus importante 9 % des cas locaux
concernent des affaires relatives au
séjours des étrangers Louis se souvient
de deux mères de famille syrienne venu
lui demander de l'aide la préfecture
leur demandait de retourner dans leur
pays pour renouveler leur visa elle ne
pouvait pas puisque les consul été fermé
et donc le problème ça a été de faire
prendre localement par le préfet une
décision exceptionnel d'autorisation
provisoire de séjour pour leur permettre
de de de rester sinon il y avait un
danger grave pour les enfants eux-mêmes
d'ailleurs parce que ils risquaient de
pas recevoir de pas revoir leurs parents
et ce qui s'est passé par la suite en
Syrie prouve que leurs crainte était
tout à fait fondé quoi les délégués
règlent majoritairement les conflits à
l'amiaable mais en cas extrême font
appel au défenseurs des droits qui peut
demander des sanctions
disciplinaires le site du futur
Vélodrome de Montini le Bretonneux
victime d'un vol par réraction en fin de
semaine dernière la porte d'entrée d'un
autrep a été forcée afin de dérobber 10
tourets de câble de cuivre de 5000 m un
préjudice de près de 10000 €. le cuivre
qui décidément attise bien des
convoitises ce matin un autre vol s'est
déroulé dans le département à
Saint-Germain enlaai sur la
rd184 les câbles électriques reliant les
feux tricolores des carrefours de la
croix de Noa et de la Fête des Loges ont
été dérobé entraînant une importante
pagaille pour la
circulation crise humanitaire action des
des mouvements rebells et risque d'un
conflit religieux la situation de la
Centrafrique inquiè et la France
notamment demande une mobilisation de la
communauté internationale une actualité
qui trouve écour dans ce département
hier à saint-sir l'école Lionel Sagara
Moret a tenu une conférence de presse
officier français au fonctionnaire du
service des protections des hautes
personnalités il est le fondateur d'un
mouvement baptisé miracle qui propose un
plan de sauvetage pour son pays une
charte des valeurs qui doit permettre de
moderniser l'état je vous propose
d'écouter son témoignage au micro de
Patrick Jacques de dixm
j'appelle au monde entier de savoir que
la Centrafrique est un pays
francophone avec une histoire fort
française nous avons la
chance d'avoir une langue commune qui
est le Sango qui est parlé par les
4500000 habitants que nous sommes la
population
centrafricaine a une espérance de vie de
44 ans 60 % de la population de
centrafricaine à moins de 20 ans c'est
une population si elle est mal gérée
aujourd'hui c'est un chaos à cet
endroit-là et nous avons donc des
propositions pour fabriquer une armée
qui à la fois éduquer la notion de la
patrie de la
sécurité du pays et pourquoi pas la
sécurité alimentaire la sécurité de la
vie sociale parce que l'armée peut
également produire de la prévention
faite par les plus jeunes le conseil
municipal des jeunes de guillancour a
organisé une session de prévention
routière l'objectif mieux connaître les
panneaux de signalisation afin d'obtenir
son permis vélo Catherine zulato Antony
reche et vas-y tu peux y aller un pied
sur voilà appu fort une opération pour
les jeunes faite par les jeunes le
conseil municipal junior de guilloncour
a proposé une session de sécurité
routière un parcours ludique pour bien
étudier les panneaux céder le passage
stop passage piéton ou feu rouge tout ce
que l'on peut croiser dans un trajet au
quotidien l'objectif obtenir sont permis
vélo il y a des voitures qui roulent
beaucoup trop vite puis même des vélos
qui sont imprunants qui passent au feu
rouge qui grillent les stops qui soit
plus prudent qui soit initié au danger
pour voir un peu ce qu' risque chaque
jour en grillant un feu rouge ou en ou
ne laissant pas la priorité à une
voiture ils connaissent les les panneaux
ils savent s'arrêter un stop ils savent
qu'il faut s'arrêter au feu maintenant
c'est effectivement je pense que les
parents devrait plus leur expliquer les
risques qu'il courent s'il ne s'arrêtent
pas c'est à cet âge là où il faut leur
apprendre les bons réflexes les bons
gestes pour la suite les fameux panneaux
comment ces enfants les perçoivent nous
leur avons tout simplement posé la
question qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire au
Stu alors faut s'arrêter et regarder
c'est quoi le panneau où il faut faire
vraiment attention euh le panneau stop
pourquoi parce que il y en a si il y a
des voitures il roulent vite il y en a
ils peuvent traverser le panneau avec la
croix
tu sais tu sais ce que c'est maintenant
ou pas bah ouais non c'est un peu
compliqué ouais du côté de la police
municipal on réglait les freins on
revoyait les fixations car un vélo bien
entretenu limite les risques de chute et
si tout avait été bien assimilé les plus
jeunes ont pu repartir avec leur permis
[Applaudissements]
vé culture l'invité de cette édition
Jacques Pornon bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur de la scène nationale à
Saint-Quentin en evveline le théâtre qui
fête ses 20 ans cette année bon
anniversaire merci beauoup forcément
cette circonstance 27 septembre
1993 date de l'inauguration après 3 ans
de travaux à Montini le bretonnais
aujourd'hui ce théâtre représente quoi
en terme de fréquentation et puis de
programmation aussi en terme de
fréquentation on est à peu près à 60000
un peu plus de 60000 spectateurs il y a
un peu plus de 7000 7000 abonnés donc on
est en progression notable ces dernières
années on a pratiquement progressé de de
50 % dans 3 4 ans et en terme de de
visibilité on va dire au niveau national
on est une des une des scènes on va dire
qui qui fonctionne bien bon va dire le
mieux faut quand même pas exagérer mais
qui a une bonne une très bonne santé une
bonne visibilité et puis on a une une
originalité puisqu'on mélange les
disciplines le théâtre la danse le le
spectagen public la poésie la musique et
la musique est un un peu le Lian de tous
les disons de la saison de beaucoup de
thématiques et on on la retrouve dans
pas mal de dans pas mal de domaines
combien de représentations sur une
saison sur une saison comme celleci par
exemple 120 représentations pour un peu
près une soixantaine cinquantaine de
spectacles on est à 40 45 spectacles à
peu près mais certains spectacles sont
représentés sur des en série sur des des
des périodes plus ou moins longues et ça
permet de toucher un public très très
large vous êtes arrivés en 2006 au
théâtre de Montin breteneux à 5quants en
Yveline en 1993 vous étiez où estce
j'étais pas là j'étais je m'occupais
d'un festival de jazz qui s'appelle
banlieubleleu est-ce que vous vous vous
portiez un intérêt sur ces scènes
nationales sur ces différents théâtres
bien sûr
bien sûr parce que je me suis toujours
intéressé intéressé au théâtre je je
suis pas venu à l'inauguration de de cqu
an dueline mais j'ai conscience de
d'hérité on va dire de quelque chose qui
a été très très fort dans la et qui a
participé à la fondation de cette ville
puisque l'idée même de faire un théâtre
au cœur de la ville avec de faire appel
à un architecte comme t dit SLAs Fischer
de lui demander de de de faire quelque
chose d'assez visible et de monumental
on peut employer le mot c'était quand
même de la part des de l'État puisque
c'était l'état aménageur mais aussi les
élus un signe fort de de de marquer on
va dire la naissance d'une ville ou la
continuité de la naissance puisquelle
avait déjà 20 ans avec une place
importante pour la culture et donc la la
création de la scène nationale a
participé on va dire de cette de cette
époque là c'est une scène nationale ça
peut peut-être préciser ce qu'est une
scène nationale c'est un statut qui
existe depuis 91 voilà il y a 70 scènes
en France qui sont répartis suroire
c'est la seule des ivelines elle est
donc financée comme son nom ne l'indique
pas par l'agglomération de 50 an en
iveline en premier lieu et également par
l'État et puis aussi euh par le le
Conseil Général des des ivelines et puis
concernant l'action culturelle un
financement aussi de la du conseil
régional euh d'Île-de-France ça vous
oblige à certaines vous avez certaines
obligations sur la programmation alors
la
la comment dire il y a trois il y a
trois axes forts pour une scène
nationale c'est ce qu'on appelle la
diffusion la diffusion des spectacles
déjà existant c'est la création et
chaque année on a une bonne douzaine de
créations dans nos murs euh qu'on
accompagne des d'artistes qu'on
accompagne dans différentes disciplines
et puis c'est l'action culturelle al ça
c'est la partie la moins visible mais
c'est le travail qu'on fait en direction
des des des jeunes publics mais aussi
des moins jeunes et par exemple le
vendredi dernier c'était le jour
anniversaire exact de l'inauguration de
la de la scène nationale et bien on
lançait une opération qui s'appelle
cosif Chuli c'est la création d'un opéra
qui aura lieu en fin de en fin de saison
avec alors c'est c'est j'en parle parce
que c'est vraiment représentatif on va
dire de du travail qu'on fait
aujourd'hui à la scène nationale c'est
une création avec commande à un musicien
un grand compositeur qui s'appelle
Nicolas Baker qui a fait des musiques de
film qui a énormément travaillé pour
l'opéra et cetera et cetera qui a écrit
des symphonies et autres commande d'un
livret à Eric Emmanuel schmidth qui est
quand même pas quelqu'un d'inconnu et
direction de l'orchestre par le de
l'Opéra foco par David Stern qui est en
résidence au Théâtre a un fil rouge et
çaem des rouge on a l'idée de la
résidence d'artiste puceque l'opéra foco
est en résidence depuis plusieurs années
on a l'idée de la création l'idée du
travail avec les publics et vendredi
donc on a présenté ça au public qui sont
intéressés par le par le par l'opération
donc il y a deux classes qui vont
participer avec les les les
professionnels sur sur scène au moment
de la création et et puis événement
incroyable l'auteur était là Éric
Emmanuel Schmidt le compositeur et le
chef d'orcheste pour présenter ça à un
public très nombreux puis qu'il y avait
à peu près 1000 personnes dans la salle
et beaucoup beaucoup de beaucoup
d'enfants de jeunes et de familles voilà
une manière on va dire de célébrer à
notre façon les les les 20 ans les 20
ans vous avez parlé du public justement
quelle était la consigne lorsque vous
êtes arriv en 2006 le théâtre national
avait 13 ans derrière lui on vous a
donné un message est-ce que c'était
justement de s'ouvrir au plus grand
nombre de rester ouvert pour le grand
public disons que ça faisait partie de
mon projet parce que une caractéristique
d'une scène nationale c'est le directeur
est choisi sur le projet qu'il présente
et effectivement ça faisait partie de
mon projet donc je pense que j'ai été
retenu aussi pour ça donc on a mis en
place la 16 en jeunes publ qui s'est pas
mal développé ces dernières années sur
50 ans d'line en partenariat évidemment
avec toutes les autres scènes de la de
l'agglomération et puis l'autre volet ça
a été effectivement de développer les
actions culturelles en en milieu
scolaire et au-delà associatif puisqu'on
travaille aussi bien avec les écoles
primaires secondaires l'université
puisquon a un atelier de théâtre avec
l'université qu'avec Pôle Emploi qu'avec
des
associations sociales on va dire des
maisons de quartier et cetera et on est
ce que peu de gens savent on travaille
sur pratiquement pas toutes les ivelines
faut pas exagérer mais sur un très grand
nombre de communes puisqu'on est sur 40
communes des des ivelines donc il a pas
uniquement 50 an uniqu 50 an il y a la
moitié du public en gros vient de
Saint-Quentin et on est très évidemment
très très implanté sur Saint-Quentin il
y a une grande circulation des publics
sur la aglomération mais l'autre moitié
on va dire vient du département et
finalement à peu près 10 % vient
d'ailleurs hors région parisienne on va
dire nous sommes aller rencontrer
quelques habitants de C quenttins en
Yveline tout simplement pour leur
demander ce qu'ils pensaient de ce
théâtre de cette scène nationale voici
quelques réactions recueillies cet
après-midi ben je pense que c'est un
lieu agréable parce que de temps en
temps ça nous permet non seulement de
nous distraire mais également de
distraire les enfants donc pour moi
j'espère que c'est l'endroit bien les
retombé il semblerait que c'est pas mal
comme théâtre
ok donc je pense que j'irais quand même
voir parce que ce serait c'est quand
même dommage de courir à Paris à chaque
fois alors qu'on a un théâtre théâtre 50
ans ni je trouve parfait c'est très bien
je trouve c'est tout j'y vais souvent
bah j'aime surtout les les pièces de
théâtre et ça m'est arrivé aussi de voir
des Balas très très bien c'est une bonne
chose c'est pas t les villes qu' ont une
cette chance àoir le théâtre ben j'y
vais très peu ma fille va de temps en
temps et elle est assez contente mais je
peux pas vous donner une bonne opinion
parce que j'y vais très peu il y a
encore un public à aller chercher hein
malgré tout mais je vois ça mais en même
temps je vous remercie beaucoup parce
que c'est très très intéressant d'avoir
un regard objectif comme ça et on va
dire quand c'est nous qui interrogons le
public on on se dit bon ils ont envie de
nous dire que c'est bien mais mais que
vous l'yez fait comme ça dans la rue et
ce qui me surprend à moins que vous ayez
sélectionné les les il y a forcément
toujours une part de sélection les
passant c'est que ils connaissent tous
le théâtre et je sais qu'une peut pas le
rater hein ceci dit vous le disiez tout
à l'heure en introduction c'est un un
bâtiment imposant he on peut pas le
rater c'est vrai mais c'est vrai que je
sais qu'une étude alors j'ai pas les
chiffres à donneré peut-être que vous
vous les avez eu il y a une étude
récente de l'agglomération qui qui a
questionné le le la population sur le la
visibilité on va dire de de la politique
culturelle et beaucoup de gens citent le
le théâtre en premier dans leur alors je
nai pas ces chiffres mais je tout même
rapper qu' 8 c'était 40000 spectateurs
et qu'aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est plus de 60000 qui a eu
cette cette forte progression quels sont
les les objectifs justement pour pour la
suite pour vos 10 prochaines années
peut-être ben les objectifs pour la
suite si vous voulez c'est comme vous
vous l'avez dit vous-même il y a encore
beaucoup beaucoup de de public à à
conquérir il y a encore beaucoup de gens
même très proches qui savent pas qui ne
connaissent pas l'existence du théâre de
50 ans d'ine parce que il faut quand
même venir au centre saqutin Centre Gare
on va dire pour le pour le voir là
évidemment on le rate pas mais si on
habite 5qutin enline voir le reste des
ivelines et qu'on passe pas par là on a
quand même des moyens de communication
qui sont limités et et bon heureusement
vous êtes là on va dire mais ça suffit
pas et donc il y a encore beaucoup de
gens qui ignorent tout simplement
l'existence sans compter évidemment les
publics qui sont on va dire éloigné de
la culture pour lesquelles on développe
une action culturelle importante donc on
parle d'ailleurs tout au long de l'année
sur cette antenne et si vous voulez vous
souvenir un petit peu de ce à quoi
ressemblait le théâtre il y a quelques
années même au niveau de au moment de la
création il y a une vingtaine d'années
il y a un blog qui a été lancé sur
lequel on peut retrouver quelques
coupures de presse vous pouvez aussi
laisser vos propres témoignages vos
souvenirs de de ce théâtre de ces 20 ans
du du théâtre pour l'instant vous avez
quelques retours il y a eu quelques
éléments qui ont été postés sur ce blog
qui permett de bien sûr il y a des
photos il y a des témoignages qui
commencent d'arriver les gens peuvent
donner aussi des des des des vidéos
enfin ce qu'ils ont ce qu'ils ont envie
de de d'exprimer on va dire du du du
plus profond d'eux même au sujet de ce
théâtre et comment ils l'ont il a il a
éventuellement accompagné leur
accompagné leur vie on va dire s rentrer
dans la polémique c'est un jour de fête
c'est un anniversaire malgré tout vous
êtes pleinement satisfait du soutien à
la scène nationale on en a déjà parlé
par le passé quelquefois des subventions
qui sont plus ou moins difficiles à
obtenir des programmations qui ne se
font pas disons que ça commence d' être
difficile l'agglomération ménage pas son
soutien elle continue d'ailleurs de de
prendre en charge directement un certain
nombre de frais d'entretien et cetera
donc ça c'est quelque chose d'important
c'est vrai que du côté de l'État on
aimerait bien que le financement de
l'État se se renforce et puis le
département aussi de façon à ce que
justement on puisse élargir notre notre
champ de d'activité et donner plus de
satisfaction public parce que vous me
posez la question de l'avenir c'est
clair que la dynamique qu'on vit ces
dernières années montre qu'il y a une
possibilité d'évolution vers un un
nombre plus grand de spectateurs mais
aussi davantage de création on aménage
par exemple des temps et ça ça ne se
voit pas des temps de répétitions pour
les artistes et récemment encore donc la
semaine dernière une pièce de théâtre
été répétée pendant un mois entier dans
le petit théâtre qui sera présenté dans
l'année donc chaque fois qu'il y a
vacances le théâtre n'est pas vide il y
a les artistes qui travaillent et ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on pourrait
encore qu'on pourrait encore développer
et et faire de ce de ce théâtre on va
dire un lieu de création
davantage enfin plus fort on va dire
dire et puis tourner vers
l'international puisque comme vous
l'avez remarqué dans la programmation il
y a des il y a des des des temps forts
on va dire avec des artistes comme les
d'oclan donelan par exemple murencene
anglais qui qui présente tubroi en
français je je tiens à le dire dans une
version complètement folle et déjantée
vous avez akramkan un grand chorégraphe
anglais et cetera donc on pourrait aller
plus loin on va dire dans dans cette
direction là ce sera peut-être un beau
cadeau d'anniversaire voilà pour la
scène national merci jacquon d'être venu
sur ce plateau directeur de de ce
théâtre qui fait donc ses 20 ans cette
année merci à vous merci beaucoup autre
anniversaire celui de Déclic Théâtre qui
fête aussi ses 20 ans la compagnie
d'improvisation de trappe fondé
notamment par Alain deg di papi
découvrir de talents dis sadumbia Arnaut
sa mère en passant par sopia RAM encore
Jamel de Bou pour célébrer tout ça un
fiestacle est prévu le 12 octobre à
20h30 à la Merise un fiestacle
comprenait un spectacle emprunt de
festivités avec de la musique de
l'humour des célébrités également pris
des places entre 8 et 15
€ thibo est ambassadeur du Téléton 2013
atteint d'amiotrophie spinal c'est
muscle ne fonctionne pas normalement une
maladie dégénérative qui touche environ
un enfant sur 10000 en France le gène
déficiant a été découvert à la fin des
années 90 mais il faut maintenant que
les chercheurs trouvent le moyen de le
reprogrammer les parents de thba restent
optimistes et espèrent voir les
recherche aboutir avant l'adolescence de
leur fils une rencontre avec yolen tores
et Jonathan vilman pour TV
fil thibo a 5 ans il est atteint d'une
maladie rare l'amyotrophie spinale elle
touche environ un enfant sur 10000 en
France et empêche les muscles de
fonctionner normalement voilà ça c'est
camion
essence donne
peur cette année avec ses parents
livivelinois fait partie des CIN
familles ambassadrices du Téléton et il
a déjà quelques scouop à nous livré il
para qu'il nous amène dans un endroit il
a des jeux et ça c'est cible pour les
fauteuils scolarisé dans une école
traditionnelle thibo est accompagné
d'une auxiliaire pour ses gestes du
quotidien à la maison tous les jours
c'est aussi 3 qu heures de soins avec
les parents et le kiné des journées bien
rempli mais pas de quoi épuiser le jeune
garçon toujours très
positif c'est des trains de rus les gens
sont souvent étonnés quand ils le voient
arriver quelque part avec un grand
sourire il nous demande mais mais il est
heureux et oui on peut être handicapé et
heureux si vous voulez j'ai trouvé des
marrons des marrons dans mon école il
est tellement positif combatif qu'il
essaie de tirer profit de de n'importe
quoi et puis ben finalement il va
s'entousiasmer des des petits bonheurs
de la vie et donc c'est ce qui fait
qu'il est qu'il est heureux et qu'il
profite malgré tout des joies des
enfants de son âge et comme tous les
enfants de son âge lui aussi rêve de son
futur métier
oui en plus j'en ai trois et c'est quoi
ces métier bu avion ah oui d'accord va
falloir choisir ah oui c'est l'un des
trois actuellement aucun traitement ne
peut le guérir le gène déficient a été
découvert dans les années 90 mais il
faut maintenant que les chercheurs
trouvent le moyen de le reprogrammer les
parents de thibo il croi ils espèrent
que les recherches aboutiront avant son
adolescence mais il faut faire vite très
vite car la mal est évolutive et les
contraintes de son handicap vont aller
en grandissant oui on est
optimiste mais ça reste quand même une
course contre la montre ce qu'on
souhaite c'est
que la recherche puisse déboucher
aboutir le plus vite possible de façon à
ce que on puisse au moins stabiliser sa
sa situation quoi cette année encore des
milliers de bénévoles du tééton vont
tenter de récolter un maximum de de don
pour la recherche le weekend phare de
l'action est prévu les 6 et 7 décembre
prochain tu peux descendre papa oui je
peux descendre oui
merci rendez-vous donc en décembre pour
cette nouvelle édition du Téléton je
vous retrouve demain en direct à 18h
puis à 19h et 22h30 les précédentes
éditions du journal sont à consulter en
replay sur notre site internet
excellente
soirée
[Musique]